do you know other white supremacists i
just found out about is shapiro
ben is a white soprano i didn't know
that
last i checked the white supremacists no
not so hot on the chosen people
but there was a
meme that was going around listing ben
as a white supremacist i said okay this
has got to be from some far left radical
group probably some group that doesn't
have any power right it's the center for
progress and advancement and antifa and
oh no it's from google
it's from google the most powerful
company on earth
google is holding a quote-unquote
anti-racist training for its employees
and it claims that there's a direct link
between ben shapiro
and mass murder
there's a graphic it's called the white
supremacy pyramid
it shows that
at the bottom of the pyramid this is the
sort of broadest level of white
supremacy is the phrase all lives matter
that's white supremacy so if you say
that white people shouldn't just be
summarily executed you're a white
supremacist
that so all lives matter
you're beginning then you move up to ben
ben is right above that that's on
minimization that's so that's the white
supremacy thing and some other guys next
to him i don't know then
two spots up you see trump
and then
i don't know some other people of
violence and then mass murder so shapiro
i i do look i'm not saying that ben is
totally innocent okay he does have
murder in his heart every time he looks
at me but otherwise i don't think he's a
very violent guy he's a sort of
mild-mannered
orthodox jew generally not welcomed by
the skinheads this is what we're up
against and we can we're laughing about
it it's funny
google
has
more power
than
just about any institution in the
country i would say the government sort
of has more power but google and the
government are not so easily separated
google and the government own multiple
properties together
google in many ways is part of the
government they're the enforcement arm
they're a proxy for the government to do
the government's dirty work very often
the the
disparities of power
are unprecedented right now
google's power compared to the power of
the american people
is is so radically greater
i don't think there's any comparison in
history they control our speech they
control our behavior in some ways they
know every single thing about us they
know more about us than we know about
ourselves
and they run the government
and they're calling some people mass
murderers so what happens what happens
if you are successfully labeled a white
supremacist a mass murderer a genocidal
maniac
you can very easily be censored
ostracized or have violence committed
against you
that's the point
it's it would be
defensive
the implication here from the google
slide is that if you
kill ben shapiro it's self-defense
because ben shapiro's leading to mass
murder
it'll it only follow they won't come out
and say it outright but that's
the inevitable implication
and ben is a stand-in for you and me ben
he's pretty mainstream right
there are people who are to the right of
ben shapiro many of them
all of those people
absolutely not permitted
in the public discourse
i'm so glad you liked that clip i want
you
to love the whole show okay which you
can watch here on youtube you can
subscribe leave a comment
you can also get it at apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play it's
wherever you get your audio podcasts you
you subscribe for free maybe leave a
five-star review i don't know we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you